[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir eröffnen heute die
Erdbeersaison und ich habe heute schon
ein richtig geniales und sehr einfaches
Rezept für euch nämlich einen Erdbeer
Blechkuchen mit Pudding denn ich
verbinde mit Erdbeeren echt immer so den
Vanillepudding aber auch so ein leckeren
Boden vanille-boden den machen wir heute
und damit starten wir jetzt auch ich
schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz genau
Mengenangaben hier unten in die Infobox
dann könnt ihr euch das einfach
screenshotten und direkt einkaufen gehen
und Nachmachen ich habe jetzt hier die
Eier in die Rührschüssel das
funktioniert natürlich auch mit einem
Handrührgerät aber ich benutze jetzt
einfach heute die Küchenmaschine heute
bin ich ein bisschen faul
[Musik]
so zu den Eiern habe ich jetzt noch
Zucker eine gute Prise Salz die hebt
nämlich noch mal den süßen Geschmack und
Vanilleextrakt gegeben und das ganze
wird jetzt ca 2 Minuten lang richtig
schön cremig geschlagen
[Musik]
so fluffigen Masse dann einfach nur noch
Milch und Öl dazugeben ich habe jetzt
noch nicht gerührt den ich rühre gleich
nur ganz kurz also für wenige Sekunden
und vorab werde ich hier auch schon mal
mehl mit Backpulver verrühren hat
einfach den Grund dass ich das vorab
einfach schöner und besser miteinander
vermischt ihr müsst in dem Fall die
trockenen Zutaten nicht sieben das ist
bei diesem Rührteig nicht notwendig und
sobald ihr dann die trockenen Zutaten
auch nur so kurz wie notwendig also
wirklich nur ein paar Sekunden unter
gerührt hat ist der Teig auch schon
fertig
[Musik]
so der Teig ging jetzt echt super
schnell den Ofen habe ich auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 180 Grad Ober- und
Unterhitze mein Backrahmen habe ich hier
auf mein Backblech gelegt unten drunter
ein Backpapier ich habe jetzt natürlich
meinen komplett geradees Backblech es
kann sein dass ihr bei einem Ofen ein
Backblech mit so einer Mulde
mitgeliefert bekommt es kann dann auch
sein dass der Teig manchmal sich in der
Mitte sammelt und dann in der Mitte noch
leicht pappig roh ist und außen aber
schon trocken daher immer mein Tipp ein
geradees Backbleche zu verwenden und ich
habe jetzt hier meinen Backrahmen
eingestellt auf was haben wir 26 mal 36
cm da wird der Teig jetzt eingefüllt
glatt verstrichen und dann braucht er
auch nur so 14 bis 16 Minuten mach doch
gerne die Stäbchenprobe dass er schön
gar ist aber auch nicht zu trocken wird
[Musik]
so weiter geht es mit der
vanillepuddingschicht wir machen es
jetzt ein bisschen untypisch aber super
einfach hier kommt Milch in einen Topf
oder in die hochrandpfanne so und da
gebe ich jetzt nicht Speisestärke so wie
man es vielleicht kennt oder Eigelb dazu
ich mache es ganz einfach wir nehmen
Mehl und das Mehl sollte vorab Klümpchen
frei verrührt werden also den Herd noch
nicht einschalten
so Mehl bindet nämlich auch und das
bindet auch noch mal ein bisschen anders
als Stärke also die Konsistenz mag ich
jetzt in diesem Rezept lieber wenn ich
Mehl verwende statt Stärke die
Konsistenz ist einfach so ein bisschen
anders Stärke hat er dann so dieses
leicht geleeartige noch da kommt jetzt
auch noch Zucker rein für die Süße und
natürlich Vanilleextrakt weil sie einen
Vanillepudding werden soll und dann
verrühren wir das wie gesagt Klümpchen
frei und dann wird das unter ständigem
Rühren einmal aufgekocht und dann liegt
es ein in der Zeit ist unser Boden
fertig der Ofen äh jeden Moment und dann
kann man den auch schon darauf
verstreichen
übrigens wenn es nicht ganz so gut
geklappt hat und ihr noch ganz leichte
mehlklümpchen drin hat nimmt einfach ein
Pürierstab und püriert dann einmal kurz
durch für ein paar Sekunden und dann
sollte das auf jeden Fall wieder
funktionieren
[Musik]
Ofen hat gepiept wir machen mal die
Stäbchenprobe einfach ein
Schaschlikspieß nehmen reinstechen und
dann zack bleibt nichts hängen ist
fertig kann ich also direkt rausnehmen
[Musik]
ach das hier oh das ist so das ist ein
Blumenstrauß also haben sie nicht hatten
Hochzeitstag gestern ich habe meinem
ganzen Leben noch nicht so einen fetten
Blumenstrauß bekommen für mich echt
riesig gefreut und ich will jetzt ganz
viele Videos drehen damit der ganz viel
hier im Hintergrund steht ihr könnt mir
ja mal in die Kommentare schreiben damit
ich euch auch mal wieder so ein bisschen
näher kennenlerne seid ihr Single oder
verheiratet wie alt seid ihr habt die
Kinder schreibt mir das mal rein da kann
ich euch nämlich ein bisschen näher
kennenlernen und ich gehe jetzt hier mal
über zu den Erdbeeren weil ich muss
jetzt eigentlich warten dass mein
Pudding auskühlt ich konnte den warmen
Pudding auf den warmen Boden streichen
das ist gar kein Problem jetzt aber muss
die Oberfläche komplett auskühlen bevor
wir die schön frischen Erdbeeren
auflegen aber ich mache so dass ich
jetzt hier einfach schon mal
fein schneide dann kühlt das ab und dann
kommen die Erdbeeren drauf
[Musik]
so jetzt ist die Oberfläche abgekühlt
das heißt ich kann jetzt hier schon mal
die Erdbeeren verteilen ich mache das
gerne vorab bevor ich den Tortenguss
anmische weil das muss ja dann gleich
auch relativ schnell gehen und noch
besser ist es wenn ihr halt wie ich die
Erdbeeren schön klein schnibbelt weil
ich habe das auch schon mal gemacht das
Rezept mit größer geschnittenen
Erdbeeren und da ist es dann ein
bisschen schwieriger das
durchzuschneiden deswegen ist es ein
bisschen angenehmer wenn die richtig
schön klein sind die Stücke oh das sieht
schon richtig gut aus so das habe ich
jetzt einmal grob verteilt
dann kommt wie gesagt einfach nur noch
roter erdbeerguss oben drauf das
versiegelt ja auch noch mal die
Oberfläche dadurch wird es auch nicht so
schnell matschig das heißt ihr habt viel
länger was davon wenn er überhaupt so
lange hält weil der ist schon echt
lecker das Gute ist ja gleich so ein
großes Blech für die ganze Familie da
habe ich jetzt hier den ganz normalen
roten Tortenguss von der Kaufland
Eigenmarke übrigens falls es nicht
gemerkt habe dieses Video entsteht auch
in Zusammenarbeit mit Kaufland ich gehe
wenn es ums Backen geht und generell
halt sowieso immer zu Kaufland von daher
findet ihr dort immer alles und das wird
jetzt einfach mit Zucker und Wasser
aufgekocht eingedickt und dann geben wir
das ganz vorsichtig über die Erdbeeren
[Musik]
so nachdem ihr den Guss habt auskühlen
und fest werden lassen sind die
Schnitten auch schon fertig ihr könnt
sie jetzt natürlich wenn ihr mögt noch
mal eine Stunde kühlen aber sie sind
eigentlich sofort verzerrt bereits
sobald alles abgekühlt ist und sie
halten im Kühlschrank bis zu drei Tage
also Tag eins ist halt der Tag der
Zubereitung können es aber auch am
Vortag zubereiten und am nächsten Tag
servieren und habe damit sogar noch zwei
volle Tage sie ist zu verzehren aber wie
gesagt die sind so lecker die atmet ihr
glaube ich einfach weg und ich würde mal
sagen viel Spaß beim Nachbacken wenn du
meinen Kanal noch nicht abonniert habt
dann holt das jetzt gerne kostenlos nach
damit ihr auch die nächsten Erdbeer
Rezepte nicht verpasst und dann sehen
wir uns auch beim nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]